this is a guy named Tony Thurmond he is
the California state superintendent of
Public Instruction
and here he is going after parents who
want to know a bit more about what their
kids are learning and whether teachers
are telling boys that they're girls
we want to turn to education for
tonight's newsmaker with book bands and
lgbtq plus students feeling unwelcome in
places across the country one state is
fighting back California the governor
Gavin Newsom and Democrats in Sacramento
they're rolling out new penalties for
school districts that break States rules
among them threatening a 1.5 million
dollar fine to a school district that
refuses to back a state curriculum
mentioning the late California gay
rights leader Harvey Milk investigations
and board Decisions by conservatives new
laws to punish schools that ban books
and just the last week a new lawsuit
against the school district that's
challenging a policy that requires
schools to notify families when a child
says they identify as transgender or use
different names or pronouns Tony Thurman
he's California's state superintendent
of Public Instruction and is exploring a
run for governor and he's joining me now
Mr superintendent thanks for joining us
on this appreciate it
um so only a handful of blue states have
taken any direct action against School
boards New Jersey Illinois that is to
name a few none though as aggressive as
California why take these steps now
you know our students are calling out
and asking for help against Maga
extremists who are threatening them
literally threatening them and sadly the
actions of some of the board majorities
in our state are leading to violence
against those who are in the lgbtq plus
community and against students of color
there is so much there I mean first off
the way MSNBC The televised mental
institution the way that they frame that
whole thing but okay fine uh the fact
that this guy they're already teasing
him you can see the way the machine is
going oh we're teasing him as he may run
for governor because you know what oh
that Gavin Newsom guy he's going to be
running for president you can see it
guys like just look through the thing
and start seeing it and then of course
this guy he wants to go after school
boards the better way to be framing that
is you're going against parents parents
are on school boards they're interested
in a little transparency they want to
know what their kids are learning who's
teaching them these things etc etc and
we're going to find school boards one
1.5 million dollars if you don't learn
about Harvey Milk I'm guessing that in
most of these schools they don't teach
that Harvey Milk was also having an
affair with a 16 year old boy yeah
Google it for yourself but okay fine
fine uh here he is the same guy they had
one of these school board meetings and
the parents have had it with him and he
actually got thrown out of a school
board meeting which must prove his
theory about magic Maga agreement
extremism sure
you'll not bully us here in Chino please
see
[Music]
[Applause]
then Chino
five minute break chaos in Chino as the
state superintendent of Public
Instruction is escorted out of the
public meeting of the board of education
but what I saw here tonight was just
catering to a mob mentality that has
disregard for the safety of many of our
students who are vulnerable and at risk
the emotions explode as the state
superintendent ends his public comment
period bringing a heated exchange with
the school board president as a point of
order as the Border this is not your
meeting you may have a seat because if I
did that to you in Sacramento you would
not accept it
you're not going to Blackmail us all
this as emotions run high with the Chino
Valley Unified School District set to
vote on a controversial proposal it
would require teachers and School staff
to notify parents if a child identifies
as transgender
even the way that was framed and that
was Fox it's controversial to know if
your kid is being secretly taught that
they're a girl if they're actually boy
that's not that should not be
controversial it's only controversial
because you people keep saying it's
controversial anyway God bless these
parents that there are still a few sane
people in California